walk into a target anywhere in the u.s
and you're likely to find sleek
mannequins elaborate displays and fancy
lighting target is very focused on the
aesthetics of their stores their
products that is what they hope makes it
feel like an elevated discount store
experience this elevated experience
which has led some to nickname the store
target is part of the company's strategy
to differentiate itself from competitors
and draw customers through the door but
what's happening in the front of a
target store is only a portion of the
retailer's secret to success
this is the economics of target
target to me is so interesting because
really there
a department store that became a
discount store and they were always
going after sort of a higher end
discount store image and that's remained
true to today
target positions itself as the option
for cheap yet chic items and customers
can see the two ideas combined when
walking around the store
in certain areas like apparel home goods
and electronics target stages items with
lavish lighting and displays but just
across the way you'll still find the
standard merchandise aisles with uniform
fluorescent lights target has always
tried to sort of meld these
like visual expectations that we have
from a department store like the
mannequins and the good lighting and
like a display for cosmetics with a
discount model they also want you to
feel like you're getting a good deal and
i think you see that as they iterate on
store designs they still strive for that
combination according to a study by hawk
incentives when a customer feels like
they're getting a good deal it can make
them feel smart and in turn increase
sales don't get distracted at target
don't get distracted at target don't get
this to oh i need that
retailers always are looking for this
balance of things that bring you to the
store that you need like a gallon of
milk and the things that you might buy
on a whim that they actually make more
money off of target store design is one
of several factors that have helped the
retailer expand in recent years the
business has grown more than 35 percent
in the last two years crossing 100
billion dollars in annual revenue driven
in large part by the pandemic and a
decision target made five years ago to
invest in its stores you know lots of
retailers said hey
amazon is here let's stop building
stores let's remodel what we have let's
develop an e-commerce model let's invest
in other things target has continued
adding stores some of them tend to be
smaller stores different types of
formats while they've invested in
e-commerce but they haven't completely
pulled back on expanding their store
account the retailer has over 1900
locations in the u.s which is smaller
than walmart but bigger than costco
around 75 percent of the us population
lives within 10 miles of one of these
stores
so target like lots of
retailer established retailers big
retailers has this huge benefit right
now which is they have the stores
already and you probably live pretty
close to one and that's enabled them to
say offer things online for pickup in
the store parking lot which has been
wildly successful for them during the
pandemic because they have that store
for you to go and pick up your online
order at
the majority of operations like in-store
and curbside pickup and fulfillment for
online orders get started in the back
room of the stores
it's been so interesting because they
started to
say like we're going to use our stores
we're not going to build big you know
e-commerce warehouses we're going to use
our stores several years ago and there
was a little bit of skepticism in the
market because it didn't seem like you
could really be that efficient in that
model but in the end they say they've
saved a lot of money because a they're
not building a huge warehouse which
costs a lot of money up front and you
know they already have the trucks coming
to their stores with their goods and
they're just using those stores to the
maximum
possibility last year target's brick and
mortar locations handled more than 95 of
over 100 billion dollars in sales
so walk around any target and you're
likely to see this operation in action
workers move carts throughout the store
gathering and scanning items
while others watch for cars pulling up
and deliver their orders in effect
target hires workers specifically for
its fulfillment operations
the company calls this role a
fulfillment expert they're either out on
the floor collecting goods off the
shelves just like a shopper or they're
in the back room packing up things into
boxes getting them labeled appropriately
they're really more like warehouse
workers and now the company is taking
this a step further in an effort to
bridge the gap between its stores and
its delivery location they're doing
these things called sortation centers
which allow them to basically
have or orders from stores that are
being packed up by fulfillment workers
sent to that more central location but
still kind of close to stores and then
picked up and sent out from there
target success is also strongly
dependent on the items in its stores
at any given time about one third of
target's inventory is exclusive to the
retailer through private labels
similarly designers will often partner
with target for a limited time capsule
collection
these capsule collections for target are
sort of marketing right it's a way to
say hey we're high design big designers
are interested in working with us so it
gives them a little bit of that cachet
these collections are nearly as
fundamental to target as its bullseye
logo in the late 90s top makeup artist
sonia kashuk partnered with target to
create a professional makeup line at
affordable prices 16 years later target
bought the line and today this line is
only one of target's more than 45
private labels they have become huge
brands for target and they've added more
and more and now it's a pretty
significant percentage of their sales
and private label like at all companies
can be lower price for the consumer but
more profitable for the retailer so
there's a big interest for any retailer
going in that direction according to a
report by cb insights retailers can earn
25 to 30 percent higher gross margins on
private labels compared to manufacturer
brands target has yet to share the
precise margin on its private labels but
currently 11 of its brands are worth at
least one billion dollars with four
brands crossing the two billion mark
while target has transitioned through
many iterations since it got its start
in 1962 changing store designs many
times and acquiring businesses within
its larger brand the company continues
to evolve with the ever-changing
customer
they tend to kind of change
strategy quickly when things aren't
working and i think we see them in the
middle of potentially another version of
that because the consumer is changing so
much right now but even as the company
evolves some aspects remain the same i
think the most consistent thing for
target has been this image this idea
that they're an elevated brand they're
different than their competitors they
have stuck with that since the beginning
and they still really lean on it today
[Music]